[Music]
Super Bowl Sunday is under way people
I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey all right so we got
this Marvel Studios Avengers end game
big game TV spot game game game game
game listen guys before we hop into this
I just wanted to say big big thank you
to everyone who has been following us
over at our patreon page over there we
do weekly q and A's and we also do TV
show reaction stream alongs for many
shows that includes my hero academia
attack on titan I just finished that
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood Gotham
Riverdale and supernatural and starting
as of this weekend we going here on out
we are gonna be doing reaction
highlights 10-minute cut downs fair use
you know that goes for Supernatural my
hero academia I'm starting up one punch
man this week so that one as well go
check us out over our patron page I
would really appreciate it anywho let's
get to this
[Applause]
some people
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my no
[Applause]
god I hope it's this dark god I love
that it's silhouette shot and I'm just
walking at the end you love seeing
rocket right there yeah Wow looks so
real it's like rocket that raccoons
really there yeah yeah yeah just the
remaining Avengers off to do God knows
what yeah I love this like dark gritty
vibe and then that even that shot at
Captain American who looks like a
support group of sorts just right there
yeah I mean everybody in the world would
have been touched by the snapping so I
just wonder who else he's talking
through there I hope this movie has this
level of like dark grit to it I mean to
something s city something as simple as
just freakin Tony Stark and nebula
working together preparing stuff this is
even that looked like I mean that's
that's been my favorite thing I guess
about this ad campaign so far as opposed
to infinity works I think infinity war
had these really thick ads that got you
look really intense and exciting stuff
like that but these are like very
deliberate they're choosing specific
images to show like who's there and how
they must be feeling and they're kind of
leaving it at that like I don't know
where the story of this is gonna go that
I'm just so into the movie you know well
I'm kind of wondering too I mean I'm
sure you guys have a better guess unless
there's a spot where rocket opens a door
and then you have a later shot where
Thor fully capped as going there's like
some type of looks like a break in a
ship I wonder if that's the planet where
Thanos is that at the end of infinity
war it kind of lay the background images
kind of look like that yeah you know I
don't know we won't know until the moon
comes out put man the way they're
setting up this real dark brooding side
of Captain America even though final
shout were him loading the shield on his
warm yeah strapping himself up this
looks like literally getting ready for a
battle it seems like and also to to cut
away and get that brief glimpse of like
Tony and nebula like up in space yeah
working on something like maybe trying
to repair this ship or something like
that and it looks like the Avengers
headquarters are at a football stadium
now you see the Avengers logo in the
background and of course the badass shot
of you know Black Widow doing the cliche
assassin thing where you're shooting
[ __ ] I'm gonna start getting closer to
my target I just wanna murder I'm gonna
shoot that nose to death yeah sense of
anguish so I just need to shoot and of
course rode in with a red light on him
and a very polished hairdo oh yeah now
he's like we're gonna go bad in the
field I'm gonna have a badass haircut
I'm gonna bring my stylist to this
valley ah man that's perfect that's
perfect I hope all the trailers are this
short yeah I know it's a Super Bowl spot
so only 30 seconds but I hope they're
all short like this from here on out
anyway got any crazy theories or
predictions from this little spot right
here man
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
go check us on patreon we'd love to have
you become a patron jek today